obviously reciprocal functions kind of
implies the base the original functions
so let's just remember in the context of
a right-angled triangle right we begin
not with trigonometric functions but
with trigonometric ratios right these
things are the names of ratios between
sides okay so if you've got your
triangle here and got feet up move it
there right but if I say sine theta
which two sides of my comparing the up
opposite opposite over here right
spacing and my knees good okay so we
learned a mnemonic write sohcahtoa so
this is s H right and you continue
cosine is C aah-ha to us that's adjacent
over hypotenuse right so I'll just fill
in the adjacent side here and ten you
can think of interior four ways which
are really the same thing okay
just like these are ratios of sides 10
is a ratio of the ratios right we define
tan as side over cos cos but of course
since there are common things with
silent cars they are both divided by the
hypotenuse right when you look at these
things over each other the hypotenuse is
they cancel right so that's why you end
up with just opposite over adjacent
which is what gives you the TOA
of socket on okay
all right so this is where the ratios
begin now these guys have all of their
corresponding reciprocal functions okay
so if you want to put these over here in
parallel okay 1 over sine the reciprocal
of sine we call that Kosek you'll
sometimes sometimes see that abbreviated
as C s see I'm not a huge fan of that
for reasons you'll see in a second not
like it takes you know wow there's two
letters save point four seconds you know
I'm just gonna write ko saing okay
that's whatever side so clearly that
means it's not opposite on hypotenuse
it's high point you some episodes right
okay in exactly the same way cosine has
its reciprocal 1 over cosine and that's
called a stick right and in the same way
that's gonna be on adjacent last one the
reciprocal of tan is called
curved and that means it's not opposite
of adjacent but adjacent opposite okay
no let's just sit back for a second
that's kind of when you need to be able
to answer the questions that involve
these things if you get asked to work
out what's sec theta and you've got what
these sides are then you just take the
correct ratios I just do want to give a
bit of a spoiler though well more like a
tease that these things here right they
actually refer to things it's not just
that mathematicians were sitting around
thinking hmm
what extra bits of new terminology can
I've written here to make people
memorize we've discussed this before
about where terminology comes from it
comes from people trying to understand
something so we know what that is cause
which of course is short for cosine
right relates to soon tear does anyone
know I can stands for stance I'm tangent
why does it stand or change it why would
this come to this where is the tangent
even in this diagram okay we'll talk
about those or than times these things
also are abbreviations right Kosek
stands for code secant cosecant hmm
what's a secant it's line that will
intersect with a circle twice right as
opposed to a line that intersects with a
circle once that's cosecant SEC is short
for secant and cut is short for code
tangent okay now knowing why they are
why they named those names right that's
not by the scope of the course but just
because we can we will address it and I
kind of want to leave it to you to think
well would I maybe understand what was
going on here a little more if I
understood why they were called what
they were called okay by the way
everything cop kind of comes back to
sine sine is your basic trigonometric
function and sign just comes from a word
I can't remember what language it is
that means Kobe why would why would a
curve a thing like this out of this be
named curvy well let you have a think
about that we'll get to it in time with
the reciprocal functions because if
you're like me then when you first start
to learn them and work with them it's
very hard to remember what's what so
there's a very easy way and this is why
I prefer to write cosac rather than CSC
here's what you get because you don't
usually get these in a nice grid that
tells you what everything is just
there's a question it's just got one of
them and you're trying to work out which
ones which it's really easy watch it's a
bit of a cheat but it is topic I will
teach you a variety of cheats so long as
you know what they really are and not
just rely on the cheat like I don't know
the cheat rule just says this and then I
don't care why is that as long as you
don't do that you be fine they're all
reciprocals right they correspond to
sine cos and tan I've conveniently
written them in the
but all you have to do is look at the
third letter of each one right so that's
one on sign that's one on cause and
that's one on tan there's no short way
to do it in your calculator you simply
have to go and say 1 over 10 and that'll
give you the actual number okay but that
will help you to remember what they are